le variant sud-africain débarqué c'est
toute une ville qui doit s'adapter un
dépistage massif est organisé depuis ce
mardi à richelieu où le variant sud
africain a été détectée la semaine
dernière chez les parents d'un enfant de
la halte garderie
au total cinq cas peu symptomatiques
sont avérés par ailleurs cinq classes du
collège ont dû être fermés pour cause de
covile sans que le variant ne soient
pour le moment incriminé pour briser
cette chaîne de contamination les
autorités invitent donc les ce 1700
habitants de la commune à se faire
dépister gratuitement jusqu'à demain
samuel cola est-ce que vous avez des
symptômes monsieur une heure après
l'ouverture une files d'attentes déjà
longue
vingt bonnes minutes pour arriver
jusqu'aux deux zones de prélèvement de
richelieu ou des environs il suffit de
présenter sa carte vitale pour faire un
test pcr
enfin tout le monde se renseigner c'est
plus prudent de se faire tester quoi bon
se joue mais toujours se méfier le frère
de ma fille qui a eu 20 cas dans sa
classe et du coup par précaution la
toute la famille le fait les
échantillons partent ensuite à
chambray-lès-tours les résultats sont
connus dans la foulée ceux qui sont
portés avant midi résultat ce soir ceux
qui sont tentés ce soir résultats demain
matin
en cas de positivité la personne ait
contacté directement par téléphone la
recherche des variants et maintenant
systématique on fait l'analyse qu'ovide
simple avec bien sûr un à lisieux
variant derrière samedi dernier cinq
personnes sont testées positives aux
variants sud africain à richelieu des
formes sans gravité du coc vide
l'urgent désormais empêcher les chaînes
de contamination un principe de
précaution aussi que de dépister à
maximum de personnes évalue aussi la
circulation de ces variants sud africain
le centre de prélèvement restent ouverts
demain et les tests ils sont encore
réalisables toute la journée